welcome to this video or playing drama
da this is Jasper hall i am from Sweden
and we've got this line yeah that's not
one of my favorite lines actually with
you five oops yeah most the most serious
issue for me is that I tend to forget
that tend to forget the lines was I have
a an idea what to do but I tend to
forget the precise move orders yeah this
is something that I usually like to
avoid but he got it in any way yeah I
don't know what I what went wrong there
I mean not that I'm worse but it's
really not what I usually want to have I
came um I think night see form yeah I
against Nazi phone
I'd like to trade this out so he goes
from f6 and it's easy for black to play
this position can I get in III and
before am now let's try whether they
really don't like this position not sure
what what what did I do wrong there
within water I don't know I mean as I
said it's not it's not terrible for me
it just I don't don't like this I'd
rather be black here with the center on
c5 and if I this is just a gap this
maroc c-style position I always want to
be want to be the one with the pawns and
not the one sitting there is no space
anyway night deform
Jim cannot go before as I had planned
and his maybe going with B 5 himself
well maybe maybe this is not that
convincing if he does that oh yeah I had
tonight a queen a4 was an idea that I
had but impossible let's rearrange it is
just dashing I would move after move
after move and it's relatively easy for
black to play museum cakes night b5 it's
not really nice but okay I don't see me
tolerating this night for the whole game
you know see Jake's is more logical here
than e takes but what it takes its not
bad but she takes looks more no didn't
do it she takes was more in fitting with
the rest of its set up with co indie
rock but he can do that as well now
switch to the e-file black has an
advantage anyway in both cases
I would absolutely love to get a five
and but if he just goes 95 now in
control V for Travis b6 now I mean I
didn't I don't really know if he needed
to go age five yeah this is a good move
simple and good move yeah that I'm at
least happy that he had this that he has
played all this I wonder if he fires a
move or III for that matter takes nine
ticks yeah maybe he really yes we can
just kingside quite a bit so maybe this
is an option okay after night xes night
before in fact which are overlooked and
then really overlooked okay that this is
just an totally unfortunate game from
start to finish I mean unfortunate sound
sounds like it's like I had bad luck I
just played badly and the biggest issue
is a totally dislike this position type
okay
make it go a six probably nope didn't do
it okay let's cap assy form now can I
have a can activate a pieces a little
bit then it wouldn't be half bad it's
going for a six maybe even like to put
some pressure here okay maybe this one
it's this King side some wood week this
is sam this is something that my
position as in its favor k i'm trying to
go for that even though he might be able
to take only 30 or not but i have to do
something like this now this is a bit
annoying for him I guess he didn't see
that idea so I'm winning the Queen here
after eat eggs he can take with the rook
due to that and you to that Bishop c5
resource but whatever I really didn't
have much choice so if i take it Bishop
c5 I'm morning um I would return the
Queen I can go 93 Bishop before Luke see
a check and it's not not great
difficult and still I'm still kind of
badly coordinated him so it's not like
I'm just a queen up really not mmm
that's a bit unfortunate he of course
blundered into 95 but at least the way
it turned out it's not at all grade for
me check well running into a huge
discovery here but what to do not sure
if he has a great discovered check
don't get that one so anger I'm the
queen up for a Roku or what
I had at games like this against him
quite a bit totally winning and then
he's winning on time from from a crap
position check no ma'am ok back nothing
going on just a draw but you were in on
time yeah ok that's useless right yeah I
had a very bad position and then he
completely blundered it away but I was
so down on time from having the bad
position that I couldn't recover from
that yeah I really don't know the
opening what is exactly the issue was
somehow that I was forced into this
issue maybe I have to start with a 3
before he or something I really need to
provoke 85 that so that's a huge
accomplishment meant if I can provoke
him to do that move which wasn't
necessary in the game and this 7 this
position is just good for black I mean
even if maybe some theoretician say it's
equal I don't believe it why does just
space disadvantage and sitting there it
has no idea what to do um yeah well I
kind of shuffled around here this P form
never materialized yeah i'm just-just
much much worse but yeah he simply
played very badly from yeah yeah night
before as a great move now just
attacking this but I didn't really see
anything else then sitting in this in
this bad position
yeah and now we just blundered into 95
but the thing is it is not that bad this
is the worst part yeah whites blacks
position is so active that it is still
reasonably difficult to play and I got
into problems again after which he again
blundered check yeah this is of course
okay what what what Knight g4 went back
yeah this is just yeah triple ? but 20
seconds and it's still reasonably and I
still have to make moves is pretty
active now 40 seconds again 13 seconds
or so it's difficult you can shuffle
around for quite a bit check yeah now
I'm return this and the position is a
dead rabbit of course the clock is
telling a different story yeah this is
opening result is so it's really bad
this is certainly okay and maybe here a
3d form maybe I have to start with a
three right here or here I have to have
to try to get in a five that he has to
play a five the difference is that in
this kind of position if we if we do the
same thing let's say this this okay here
i would even prevent d five altogether
but let's say he does this yeah d3d five
gigs takes Knight see two castles 93-97
and then there's this is a big
difference because now he s got an a5 in
and this is a square now me which gives
them white pretty decent play you can
for example quite often get in Queen a4
and it could be five playing on those
weak squares this is far more
interesting in comparison
I'm still not a huge fan of this but
it's much much better than what I had in
the game after where I just had a really
rotten position which ultimately led to
the huge time time consumption on my
part okay well thanks for watching